[Music]
hey what's up
i'm kphd here and this is it this is a
the sequel to the phone that
shook up the the folding phone world
last year
it was it was headline worthy this is
the galaxy
z fold 2 5g
it's the fold too and i'm shooting this
in a bit of an unusual location as you
can probably already see
i'm in a trailer in the middle of the
desert in arizona because
i'm out here essentially hosting david
blaine's
ascension project where he's gonna float
up into the sky while holding on to
balloons it's
it's kind of insane and it's a pleasure
to be here
but i figured while i'm here i will have
samsung
ship the phone out here and then i also
had andrew at the studio ship uh komodo
out here so
we're gonna do a little uh first
impressions and hands-on of this phone
before uh tomorrow there's the launch so
watch that i'll link it below if you
haven't
gotten to it yet but this is the phone
now a lot happened last year with the
galaxy fold right
but the benefit of being samsung and
just experimenting out in the open like
that
is you can make mistakes and learn a lot
from them you learn a lot more from
mistakes usually
than success and so one thing i've
noticed about the galaxy fold 2
z fold 2 is a lot of these changes
are learned directly from the fold 1. so
the box of course here
is a little bit cooler if i do say so
myself but as you get into it you'll
notice
it doesn't come with quite the same
array of accessories
like the top thing here is paperwork and
that's kind of it so you get the phone
of course
and then there's just a fast charger
included which of course you would
expect for the
two thousand dollars that this phone
will cost again this year
but this time there's no case there is
no headphones
and there's nothing else that really
feels special about the stuff that comes
with it which to me honestly is a little
bit of a bummer like i thought there was
no question this phone would come with
all that extra stuff
and then a note about the screen
protectors so we took the plastic off at
the beginning and that was all great but
the fold 2 comes with a
plastic screen protector on the front
display and
on the inside on the main display so i
asked samsung very specifically
about this the screen protector on the
front display
is cool to remove yourself and they said
that was fine
i did that easy just like any other
screen protector
but they recommend someone officially
from samsung
removes this pre-installed main screen
screen protector and i don't know how i
feel about that i
it doesn't look that great it does have
like a little bit of a haze
i feel like i'm going to want to remove
it pretty soon i'm probably going to
remove it but
i'll let you guys know on twitter when i
do attempt that but my impression here
of the phone overall really is there are
three main areas
where there are major improvements uh
and that would be
the screens the hinge and the cameras
and there's other stuff there's little
design tweaks and there's improved specs
and all that but all the rest is really
minor
or it revolves around those main three
things
i'll leave uh youtube chapter time
stamps below if you want to
skip to your favorite part so of course
like i said the specs are updated too
but we've seen those already snapdragon
865 plus
12 gigs of ram 4500 milliamp hour dual
battery
and the design i think feels more
refined you can see
it's boxier it's a little weightier and
i'm such a big fan of the satin finish
it's not even funny
it's still mystic bronze you can also
get mystic black
but it's really in the big areas where
you see not just hardware improvement
but real potentially big usability
improvement too
so let's start with the screens this
one's pretty simple
both the cover screen and the main
screen got big upgrades
the cover screen is now full size so it
goes from like that little 4.6 inch
display with huge bezels that was
i think easily the worst looking part of
the first fold
to a genuine corner to corner full size
6.2 inch display
it's still really narrow but i feel like
this alone is going to change
the way i use the fold the tiny cover
screen before was actually pretty
limiting and i didn't want to use the
phone closed as much but
now that changes a bit i feel like the
full size smartphone type of size on the
outside
will change the behavior before you even
open the thing
but then on the inside once you do open
it up there is your second
big screen change the bezels inside are
a little thinner
it's now a 7.6 inch square display
versus 7.3
but i think more importantly the huge
corner cutout from last year is gone
for just a single 10 megapixel hole
punch selfie camera and i'll talk more
about why that makes
a lot more sense in the camera section
but the bottom line is that ends up
giving you a noticeably more impressive
huge canvas of the screen like this is
what i was hoping for when i was
dreaming of
improvements for folding phones it's
impressive and this main screen is also
now
bumped up to yes high refresh rate 120
hertz
it's actually adaptive refresh rate so
it can modulate anywhere from 11 to 120
hertz depending on what's happening on
the screen but yeah
this is one of those things again that i
mentioned even last year with the fold
one
of improvements i'd like them to make
and we have it here now now one of the
things i was wondering about
is the crease since it's now using the
same ultra thin glass
on the z flip and i'm i'm seeing the
crease still it's not like it's going to
disappear after one generation
uh you run your finger over it a little
bit and you can still feel it like the
z-flip but again just like those other
phones it's not quite as big of a
problem if you're just looking at the
content
and not looking for the crease so the
screen's pretty sweet
thumbs up for me so it's just such a
what a difference that cover screen
makes right
but that brings us to the second big
piece which is the hinge
and i'm just going to keep saying it the
hinge to me feels like the most
important part of a folding device i
just got done
in my last video raving about how the
surface duo's hinge is
one of the most impressive things in any
piece of tech in a long time
and now this hinge i was kind of
trashing it before with the first fold
but now this hinge does a lot of the
same stuff so this is now the second
version of their zero gap hinge it looks
pretty similar to the first one
conceptually it's still the same
with their hinge and the back plate but
this year samsung will actually let you
customize
the back plate color between a couple i
think it's four different colors
which is super cool if you're willing to
wait a couple extra weeks for the
customization to come through but now
this new hinge
will allow for freestand anywhere from
75
to 115 degrees meaning it can basically
stay put
in almost any reasonable angle you want
and then there's a bunch of software
features
built around this new hinge that i'm
going to be testing for the full review
it's still called flex mode and there's
a slowly growing list of apps that will
recognize when the hinge is folded
halfway
and then it'll treat the app like a mini
laptop basically
uh if you're watching a youtube video
for example and half close it it'll put
the video in the upper half
or if you're in calendar or gallery they
also have special layouts
in flex mode and even the camera has a
special mode
for when it's half folded so clearly
they see people using it half folded a
lot more
because of the hinges ability to do it
makes sense and speaking of cameras
that's the last big piece here for the
fold two now the first fold
already had pretty good cameras it was
flagship quality at the time
and you again get flagship quality
cameras here triple 12 megapixel system
on the back
regular 3x telephoto and ultrawide but
that's not the big improvement here
the update is the layout of the cameras
which was kind of clunky if you remember
that big ugly cutout in the first galaxy
fold
so if you're ever to make an argument
about if this is the right way
to do a folding form factor i think the
camera layout being much smarter here
is a good argument for it so it's the
triple cameras on the back like i
mentioned
in that mesa that squared off camera
bump like the note
main camera telephoto and ultra wide
then on the inside like i said earlier
just a single 10 megapixel selfie camera
and on the front cover display again a
10 megapixel
selfie hole punch camera so you can take
photos and videos like normal with that
huge viewfinder that part's still great
but now instead of having that huge
cutout for better selfie cameras
if you really want to take a good selfie
you can just do
rear camera selfies and it'll turn on
that bigger cover display
and let you use it as a viewfinder
that's really smart i
believe this will also be coming to the
first galaxy fold but now that's just
so much better of a way to take selfies
with a high quality camera
there's also now dual preview mode which
turns on the back camera so you can show
the subject of the photo and the framing
there's just a bunch of other software
stuff being built into one ui
that will also come to the old fold but
it works that much better
because of the bigger cover display and
the improved hardware here but overall
i my impressions are pretty positive for
fold too
and a lot of the things they've done
even the smaller things feel much more
considered
for a daily driver now it's still a
folding phone it's still second gen
it's still not ip certified no dust
resistance there's still durability
questions with this hinge and the inside
screen
but a lot of the stuff they've changed
the fingerprint reader
being on the power button now the better
cameras the new software modes
the hinge that just feels a lot more
sturdy
and a lot more fluid
i like it so i'm gonna pop my sim card
in it and i'm gonna start using it as my
daily driver multitasking beast and i'm
gonna review it so let me know in the
comment section what you guys want to
know
whether it's the cameras or durability
battery
is another one it is a 4 500 milliamp
hour battery which is
not small but it's also a 7.6 inch quad
hd 120 hertz display so that's
that's not small either so there's a lot
of stuff to test and i'll check out your
comments for that but
that's been my first impression of the
escobar
galaxy z fold 2. stay tuned for the full
review
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one
peace
you